public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-françois copé est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir jean
françois et merci d'avoir accepté cette
invitation de public sénat avec radio
classique les échos et la fp deux médias
représentés ce soir par charlotte
gauthier et baptiste passe dans ces la
première ce soir bienvenus bonsoir à
vous deux jean françois copé maire de
moore en seine-et-marne
ancien président des républicains vous
avez décidé d'une certaine manière de
prendre un peu de champ avec la
politique mais vous êtes toujours
adhérente de l heure je crois ou est-ce
qu'on vous laisse toujours un peu de
place ce pas beaucoup un bon coup ou
baiona tu gagnes partie de cette place
comme qu'on ne peut pas m'enlever c'est
d'être bornes du but du bureau politique
du cas car j'avoue là les gars des bons
vous la laissez en passant en expliqué
dans cette émission au cours de laquelle
trois grandes questions vous seront
posées 1
quel est donc votre jugement sur l'an 1
de macron puisque c'est son premier
anniversaire aujourd'hui 2 qu'elle peut
être une opposition de droite ou chef de
l'état alors qu'on le voit il fait un
carton dans cet électorat
enfin troisième question les banlieues
vous êtes vraiment un mot bien placé
pour en parler il ya un programme de
rénovation urbaine qui se poursuit
est-ce que selon vous la solution est
dans le plan borloo qui a été présenté
il ya quelques jours et la première
question de cette émission vous est
posée par charlotte gauthier
[Musique]
haulotte non sens monsieur copé bonsoir
alors effectivement key finalement votre
jugement sur l'an 1 de macron un an jour
pour jour plus tard comment vous jugez
ces réformes mené au pas de course sncf
code du travail
quel bilan pour vous bafa d'abord
emmanuel macron c'est quand même le
président de droite qu'on attendait pas
et il faut toute la paix sincère
personne n'a vu venir emmanuel macron se
disait de gauche et qui depuis qu'il est
élu n'a fait que des mesures que la
droite préconise gauche ni de droite
wheelman gauche oui mais à la limite
c'est pas lui s'il j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est pas lui de le dire c'est à
nous de constater les faits et quand
vous faites la liste de toutes les
réformes qu'il a initiées depuis qu'il
est élu c'est grosso modo ce que la
droite aurait dû faire quand elle était
au pouvoir
et je peux vous dire que ça fait du bien
pour notre pays après cinq années d'un
quinquennat désastreux celui de monsieur
hollande qui aussi bien sur le plan de
la politique économique et sociale que
sur le plan régaliens malheureusement
n'a pas fait les réformes qu'on
attendait et a fait plus tôt a pris
plutôt des décisions qui étaient
mauvaises pour le pays donc c'est
incontestablement aller dans le bon sens
que de mener les réformes que monsieur
macron a commencé de faire pour vous la
meilleure réforme non celle qu'il a
menée on va goûter pour moi la réforme
qui était la plus fondatrice c'était la
réforme du code du travail par
ordonnance qui est exactement ce que je
préconise depuis des années donc je le
dis depuis des années il faut gouverner
par ordonnances sur un certain nombre de
sujets bon pour moi c'est la plus
emblématique où il ya aussi quelques
erreurs évidemment et dont certaines
très regrettable je pense que
l'augmentation de la cfdt était une
vraie erreur politique
vraiment idem d'ailleurs sur la décision
qui a été prise sur la pl pour être mère
deux mots c'est à dire une ville où nous
avons énormément de logements sociaux
est donc de locataires de ces logements
sociaux ça a été évidemment une très
mauvaise nouvelle et comme toujours
quand une décision est mauvaise elle a
pour conséquence une suite enchaîne donc
mauvaise décision et on a planté il faut
bien le dire les finances de très
nombreuses deux fils de celle m et ça
c'est tout à fait vrai t'as pas ce que
ça veut dire qu'on entretient - on a
moins d'argent pour entretenir les
immeubles
voilà le genre de chose qui a des vrais
qu'on sait qu'ils ont des vrais
consécration mondiale de réserve mais
sinon on a l'impression quand vous
faites des affaires des autres
c'est un sans-faute y en a quelques
autres mais le gleut le bilan est
globalement positif de mon point de vue
tout simplement parce qu'il fait une
politique de droite et moi je pense que
notre pays a besoin d'une politique de
trois français pas et et non c'est
pareil de droite et de gauche donc pour
vous lécher clair une fois je ferai faut
arrêter de jouer les mots de faire de
l'ambiguïté où sont les mesures de
gauche en a aucune des deux donc aucune
en vérité il a pour l'essentiel fait ce
que nous aurions nous à droite du fer
notamment
entre 2007 et 2012 je pense par exemple
à la forme de la sncf la réforme du code
du travail mais aussi c'est vrai une
reprise en main sur le plan de la
sécurité qu'il faut absolument faire
maintenant c'est un ralliement la de
jean françois copé ce soir à emmanuel
macron a pas du tout ne s'est pas du
tout prévu ça non non non d'abord parce
que si j'avais dû prendre une décision
comme celle-là je dois fait il ya
longtemps deuxièmement c'est pas ma
tasse de thé comme disent les anglais
moi je suis fidèle à ma famille
politique j'ai présidé les républicains
je n'ai absolument pas l'intention de
quitter ma famille politique avant et
donc mais pour autant je peux avoir une
comment vous dire un devoir de cohérence
c'est moi je trouve que le sectarisme
est une des formes les plus aboutis de
la bêtise humaine et donc dit
d'une mesure qu'elle est idiote ou qu'on
la conteste alors qu'on est
fondamentalement pour au motif qu'elle
est prise par quelqu'un qu'on a pas
soutenu ce site on reviendra grain sur
la tête de galère dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission baptiste
emmanuel macron c'est aussi une pratique
du pouvoir vertical jupitérienne en cela
aussi c'est un président de droite coûte
et ça c'est plus dur du domaine du
commentaire
moi je pense que les bagnoles macro faut
se calmer un peu avec tous ces
commentaires ça n'est ni jupiter son
terme à lui il faut écouter j'en sais
rien après chacun vit son ego comme il
peut mais je pense que emmanuel macron
dénis jupiter ni encore moins de gaulle
je crois qu'il faut arrêter le grotesque
si les choix d'heure c'est à dire ceux
ce chandelier allemand socialiste qui a
fait des réformes dont l'allemagne
avaient besoin et qui a permis l'arrivée
ensuite d'angela merkel qui a fait un
parcours formidable en allemagne et bien
si emmanuel macron est déjà schröder
pour la france ce sera déjà très bien
alors il ya d'autres voient dans votre
camp politique notamment celle de xavier
bertrand qui lui site market cette
chaire est dit c'est un reproche macron
satcher est ce que ça ne rejoint pas
d'une certaine manière ce que vous
disiez sur certains déséquilibres
sociaux cg ça n'a rien à voir leur est
cher ça pour le coup moi je pense que
notre pays a besoin de faire des
réformes
il y en a absolument besoin ça fait des
années que par absence de courage
politique on a reporté les décisions qui
étaient nécessaires
ces décisions commencent à être prises
et c'est vrai que dans un certain nombre
de domaines il va falloir continuer
c'est pas facile ça génère forcément des
mécontentements
je note qu'aujourd'hui il ya un concert
un certain consensus deux raisons 1 par
affectif mais de raison de 2 millions de
français
à mes yeux il y en a presque qu'il n'a
jamais été aussi fracturé le payer a
réparé cette impression non non je pense
que je pense que l'extrême gauche est
omniprésente dans la rue qu'elle est
omniprésent dans les médias qu'elle fait
beaucoup de bruit mais qu'elle n'est
certainement pas la france certainement
pas la france vous parlez de
contestation justement le président et
le gouvernement se montre très ferme
face à cette contestation que ce soit
les syndicats que ce soit les
manifestations de rue lafrance insoumise
et autres vous
tenez le président dans cette fermeté ou
vous pensez qu'il ce qui les incite au
braquage aussi et à des manifestations
extrêmes comme celle du premier mais je
pense que les les fous radicaliser
d'extrême gauche qui se conduisent avec
la violence que nous avons vue n'ont pas
besoin d' emmanuel macron pour casser
qui ce quelle que soit la personnalité
au pouvoir on le sait on voit maintenant
des documentaires qui montre cela très
clairement et vos confrères d'ailleurs
font un travail très remarquable dans ce
domaine j'ai encore vu hier sur si vous
confrères de m6 documentaire qui est
très très claire sur la manière dont ces
groupuscules radicalisait d'extrême
gauche sont organisés provoquent des
dégâts dans toute l'europe
en réalité pas donc il faut pas se
tromper c'est pas de la faute ni du
gouvernement ni des autorités se sont en
réalité des agitations l'extrême gauche
moi je vous dirai ce que je regrette
c'est qu'il y ait toujours eu en france
une certaine forme d'indulgence avec
l'extrême gauche alors qu'il y a une
très grande fermeté vis-à-vis de
l'extrême droite ce dont je me réjouis
j'aimerais qu'ils aient la même fermeté
vis-à-vis de l'extrême gauche dans les
commentaires et quand laurent berger de
la cfdt qui n'est pas un fou d'extrême
gauche non dits avec emmanuel macron
soit on est d'accord sur tout soit on
n'a pas voix au chapitre
cela va faire monter des radicalités et
la violence dans la société
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à logements
ces deux idées différentes je pense que
les radicalité n'ont pas besoin d'
emmanuel macron pour émerger émergent
régulièrement notamment dans des moments
de l'histoire où les sociétés
connaissent des transformations très
importante
le numérique intelligence artificielle
les transformations industrielles génère
forcément des frustrations et des
inquiétudes et il faut bien le dire les
décideurs politiques ont pas toujours le
courage de prendre le temps d'expliquer
partage et d'écouté etc et reporte donc
ça les radicalité elles montrent
toujours et elle profite c'est le
populisme de cela et jean luc mélenchon
comme marine le pen ont de ce point de
vue une responsabilité majeure en ce qui
concerne le premier point de la remarque
de monsieur bergé d'avoir de dire qu'ils
emmanuel macron soit on est d'accord
avec lui soit appliqué la formule que
vous avez 100 est d'accord sur tout on
n'a pas bronché soir n'a pas bronché à
pitre c'est ce que j'entends beaucoup
dire c'est peut-être d'ailleurs un petit
signal faible dont monsieur macron
devrait
s'emparer parce que cela signifie
peut-être que il y à du côté notamment
de son entourage le plus immédiat je
parle de ses collaborateurs à l'elysée
petite tendance à l'arrogance qui
mériterait sans doute d'être d'être
regardée d'un peu plus prudent kelly
d'être en prise en main il faut écouter
les syndicats
en tout cas il faut le faire d'abord il
faut écouter tout le monde sait mais
surtout il faut éviter de prendre les
gens de haut voilà et ça il faut le
savoir et attention parce que parfois
c'est de la forme mais la ferme du chef
de l'état qui l'entourent je pense que
vis-à-vis des parlementaires vis-à-vis
dé beir vis-à-vis des gens qui dans
notre pays on peut apporte parfois leur
contribution alors ils sont moins
intelligents que les collaborateurs de
mme emmanuel macron moins intelligent
qui va y avoir fait ce qu'on peut nous
avec nos petits moyens mais on peut
avoir des idées je veux dit que parfois
il serait bon j'avais des mairies un peu
d'ouvrir un petit peu c'est ses bras de
d'écouté de partage et ça je crois que
c'est important
et est ce que dit laurent berger je sais
pas je peux pas témoigner moi je ne le
vois pas ça au quotidien
moi j'ai pris un peu de hauteur
vis-à-vis de tout cela je m'occupe
beaucoup de ville de meaux et plus par
ailleurs je suis avocat mais j'invite
quand même là dessus a dit gilles ans
alors la première question de notre
sondage opinionway pour l'épreuve de
vérité c'était cette question est ce que
vous diriez que la situation de la
france depuis un an s'améliore 23% ne
change pas vraiment 40% se détériore 35%
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous à ces
procédés sondage classique on a toujours
les bras
wen ont à peu près les mêmes scores
parfois c'est pire et puis en même temps
il faut quand même être lucide en un an
patient bazbaz à ses copains qu'est ce
qu'on attendait comme changements
majeurs en un angle loi faut six mois
déjà vous imaginez faut quand même pas
non plus imaginer qu'on va passer de la
nuit à la lumière même si emmanuel
macron ses amis ont créé une dynamique
même si l'adhésion expliqué qu'il y
avait que des nuls avant et que
maintenant les génies arrivé bon la vie
est parfois plus complexe heureusement
d'ailleurs
alors dans un documentaire de france 3
qui sera d'ailleurs diffusé ce soir
emmanuel macron critique ceux qui
pensent que le summum de la lutte c'est
les 50 euros de l'apl alors ils
pensaient sans doute à des critiques
venues de la gauche mais voulait que
rond oui l'huile à 10 50 euros sans
doute qu'il a fait
sur dix mois le calcul on va l'écouter
et puis vous pourrez réagir emmanuel
macron le colonel beltrame
il est mort parce que la france sont des
idées des valeurs quelque chose d'une
guerre qui le dépasse et les gens qui
pensent que la france c'est une espèce
de syndics de copropriété où il faudrait
défendre un modèle social qui ne sale
plus une république dont on ne connaît
plus l'odeur et des principes qui fait
bien d'évoquer parce qu'on s'est habitué
à eux et qu'on a qu'on invoque la
tragédie des qu'il faut réformer ceci ou
cela et qui pensent que en quelque sorte
le summum de la lutte c'est les 50 euros
d'apl ces gens là ne savent pas ce que
c'est l'histoire de notre pays
la tirade est cassée longue et elle
nécessite d'être prises point par point
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faudrait
passer un peu plus de temps et sur le
fond et un peu moins sur la formule
encore une fois ces réformes elles sont
nécessaires et qu'on le veuille ou non
on a un président république qui a le
courage de les aider de les affronter et
de proposer de vraies décisions
après je pense que l'histoire des 5
euros c'était pas une réforme c'était
pas une réforme et que c'était une faute
politique et d'ailleurs je suis pas le
seul à dieu parce que j'ai entendu qu'un
ministre monsieur de normandie normandy
qui est très proche de lui et oui bien
sûr il regrette cette décision constitue
un considérait que c'était si c'était
absurde vous savez je pense que l'une
des éléments de définition du courage
politique c'est de reconnaître quand on
s'est trompé mais c'est pas plutôt le
style là qui choque d'emmanuel mac on
vous avait parlé de son arrogance parfum
l'arrogance de ses conseillers de son
entourage c'est plus saison son
entourage qui m'inquiète juillet mais il
adore ce qui dans ses propos dans ce
qu'il dit les français ne peuvent pas
être choqué aussi par le ton par savez y
aura des français choqués des français
pas choquer je connais par coeur les
bons pendant des années j'ai me suis
battu je continuerai et ayant toujours
de le faire pour un certain nombre
d'idées auxquelles je crois que parfois
j'ai exprimé avec des exemples concrets
que je pouvais vivre sur le terrain une
fameuse histoire aux charges cola j'en
ai pris plein la figure
aujourd'hui quand je vois ce qu'on dit
sur les dangers de l'islamisme radical
jeudi j'avais peut-être pas tort surtout
borba il faut
il faut prendre date raciste on parlait
des apl pour revenir à la politique
fiscale françois hollande dépeint son
successeur comme le président des très
riches
diriez vous que la politique menée par
emmanuel macron et équilibrée moi je
pense qu'une bonne politique c'est une
politique qui répond à des décisions
correspondant à des besoins
notre pays en réalité avait besoin d'un
certain nombre de choses il avait besoin
de se débarrasser de l'usf cet impôt
absurde qui certes concerne les gens
fortunés mais qui sinon se délocaliser
c'est une décision qui de ce point de
vue était bonne on aurait dû être prise
par la droite depuis longtemps ça n'a
pas été je pense de l'avenir allemand
débarrasser de l'usf non raison enfin
pour une partie en tout cas la partie de
l'économie financière mais vous avez
raison la question se pose pour la
partie mobile
ensuite j'ai regretté la gelée dit la
décision sur la csg je pense qu'il
valait mieux augmenter il aurait mieux
valu augmenter la tva parce qu'alors on
rendait beaucoup plus compétitive nos
entreprises ensuite est-ce que c'est une
politique est équilibrée ou parfums nous
avons la chance d'avoir un modèle social
qui est remarquablement généreux il faut
d'ailleurs de temps en temps regarder à
ce que ces abus soient corrigés ce n'est
pas là qu'il y à me semble-t-il le plus
à faire si ce n'est d'en assurer la
modernisation notamment à l'hôpital
pour le reste on a la chance de vivre
dans un pays qui est un pays merveilleux
on oublie de le dire qui permet à ceux
qui sont malades d'êtres soignés dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
est il le plus souvent sinon
gratuitement à faible coût c'est ça
qu'il faut préserver et pour le
préserver ça ne peut pas être que des
avantages acquis ça doit être aussi une
modernisation du système
dernière question d'actualité avant de
passer à la suite air france est ce que
vous estimez que l'état devrait sortir
du capital avec le blocage actuel coûte
et je crois que la situation d'un
français absolument dramatique du point
de vue de l'état d'esprit
des salariés qui montre à travers ce
référendum qui ne croient plus rien et
donc il ya un problème de gouvernance il
ya un problème de vision stratégique et
puis la preuve de lucidité par rapport à
ce qui est devenu le monde aérien et
donc face à cela c'est pas la question
n'est pas de savoir si l'état reste ou
pas dès lors qu'il est dedans il faut
qu'il dise un certain nombre de choses
et ne le fait pas c'est dommage
deuxième partie des priorités c'est
baptiste pas ce qui va vous poser cette
question jean françois copé
[Musique]
alors monsieur copé quelle place pour
une opposition de droite à ce chef de
l'état que la droite n'avait pas vu
venir mais quel décor à une bonne alors
qu'elle découvre avec bonheur
quelle place très peu très peu
il faut arrêter de tourner autour du pot
en vérité dès lors vous avez vous êtes à
droite et vous avez appris qu'un
président certes qui est pas de votre
famille politique enfin qu'il fait une
politique de droite bas il ya deux
options soit vous assumez vous soutenez
ski soutenable et il ya de quoi faire et
ce moment là vous êtes cohérent soit
vous tapez com com comme un sourd comme
on dit et à ce moment là bas forcément
vous êtes victime du syndrome
d'incohérences et d'insincérité donc
c'est un choix de vie il ya des gens qui
préfèrent paraître un sincère et
incohérent d'autres qui préfèrent être
cohérent
après c'était plus qu'à choisir donc les
gens de droite vous pensez à quelqu'un
en particulier
un sincère non parce que chacun il est
enfin y'a personne en particulier
puisque on voit bien que ça concerne
beaucoup de gens mais la pêche moi même
un patron aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est
insincère et incohérent dans sa manière
de nous relancer
un patron bah oui voilà y'a le président
de notre parti mais sera le patron
bah c'est plus compliqué non quand même
ne serait ce que parce que il faut que
ça il faut bien voir que dans une
famille politique moi j'en sais quelque
chose les présidé pendant des années il
faut faire vivre les sensibilités ce qui
compte c'est la force de chaque
sensibilité de chacun d'eux chaque point
de vue de chaque personnalité
aujourd'hui dans l'état major ya plus
aucune personnalité puisqu'il ya eu une
programme de d'évacuation systématique
alors le critère c'était de dia il
fallait faire émettre que des visages
nouveaux et c'est génial moi j'adore le
principal et pluraliste y ont même pu
riez et donc il y aura d'autres manières
de se faire entendre le moment venu
voilà ce qu'on peut dire mais ce qui est
certain c'est que vous pouvez enfin la
liberté de défendre ses idées elle se
raye pas par décret ou par éjection de
tel ou tel vous continuez de vous battre
pour vos idées heureusement dans une
grande démocratie vous avez les moyens
de le faire le moment venu
ensuite moi je vais vous dire faut que
je vous ai dit ça peu importe ça fait
même pas un enfin tout juste un an que
le président macro ont été élus tout
reste à construire et à reconstruire à
droite il faut qu'on fasse un travail
quand même de réflexion sur les raisons
qui nous a amené à ce désastre
béchir à notre avenir à notre
organisation met peut-être un peu
d'affect aussi parce que je pense que
c'est utile de mettre un peu d'effectifs
entre des hommes et des femmes qui
vivent ensemble pendant des années des
années les uns sur les autres
sous ses airs politique quand même pas
beaucoup non plus du renouvellement tout
ça c'est citera 112,2 le moment venu des
débats plus plus approfondie alors sûr
c'est beaucoup trop tôt sur ses
difficultés de la droite
aujourd'hui on écoute virginie calmels
ce qu'est la vice-présidente de l air
peut-être que surdiagnostic vous allez
pouvoir vous entendre ce qui explique
les difficultés c'est que vous le savez
notre candidat n'a pas été qualifié au
second tour de la présidentielle c'était
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
vème république la droite a donc tout à
faire pour ce recours
invoquée ne décolle pas dans les
sondages la droite à quelques mois a
repris la star pour se reconstruire
c'est pas facile on voit qu'ils emmanuel
macron tentes et continue à vouloir
faire exploser la droite c'est ça son
projet nous nous sommes des résistants
nous ne voulons pas qu'ils se retrouvent
seuls face aux extrêmes la france
insoumise où le front national alors le
front national on va en parler
qu'est ce que vous auriez répondu à
cette question comment on va expliquer
vous que laurent wauquiez à 8%
effectivement ne décolle pas dans les
sondages
vous auriez une réponse sans doute
différent enfin moi je suis pas un
expert des sondes alors je pense que je
pense qu'il fallait direction du parti a
fait un choix est respectable mais qui
n'est pas le mien qui est qui et qui est
celui de en fait de coller au discours
de marine le pen est pas forcément ça
plaît aux gens de nos électeurs de
marine le pen mais ils votent pas pour
autant pour la droite il vote pour
l'extrême-droite légende les électeurs
le pen forcément c'est normal et et
cette manière maintenant je joue ce qui
moi me terrifie d'ailleurs parce que
c'est tellement pas ma conception de
notre parti gaulliste mais beaucoup
maintenant de vos confrères disent la
ligne wauquiez le pen le pen évoqué un
esteyrie parce que ça ne représente
qu'une petite partie
l'électorat de droite quoi mais c'est
une réalité pourquoi céline gauthier le
pen laurent wauquiez dit je ne peux je
ne veux pas m'interdire de parler
d'immigration est sécurité ambassades
heureusement il me semblait alors je
vois par exemple on n'a jamais dit
pourtant dû sait si j'ai défendu la
droite décomplexée j'ai jamais entendu
dire la ligne copé le pen je n'étais pas
l'ambiance moi j'ai toujours été
extrêmement ferme par rapport à cette
question et vous avez subi les en votre
temps le même procès a donc c'est vrai
monsieur s'agit poursuit des attaques
mais comme tout le monde mais ça non
parce que justement on a été toujours
extrêmement claire par rapport à cette
question
mais au-delà de ça je pense que oui par
exemple sur l'europe
moi j'ai toujours été extrêmement clairs
sur la question européenne et je me suis
reposé l'époque ce que laurent wauquiez
voulait créer un livre qu'elle est
proposée une europe à 5
imaginez donc qui était la ligne de le
pen d'ailleurs un voilà typiquement un
sujet sur lequel il ya malheureusement à
droite une vrai débat pour ne pas dire
une fissure quand même donc c'est des
sujets complexes
alors vous me demandez moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya quand même un lien
entre entre ses résultats dans les
sondages
c'est en étant très tôt il faut donner
sa chance à laurent wauquiez il faut
laisser un peu le temps avance et vous
savez tout ça a besoin de mûrir mais
c'est un mec comme un bolide un petit
signal volume vayer d'allah même on nous
écoute vous lui dites vous fait tu fait
fausse route quand on vous écoute ça
n'est pas ce que je ferai à sa place
d'ailleurs quand j'ai été en charge ça
n'est surtout pas ce que j'ai fait
voilà pour continuer sur cette cette
question de la convergence des droite
nicolas dupont aignan qui ne perds pas
l'nord a demandé lui une rencontre avec
marine le pen et laurent wauquiez pour
évoquer leurs convergences ce matin
virginie calmels se dit bon une
rencontre mais les alliances
sûrement pas vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez maintenir en compte ni alliance
ni ambiguïté d'aucune sorte
mais puisque la convergence est telle
que vous même sens mais elle pensait
entre laurent wauquiez pourquoi ne pas
enfin je veux dire pourquoi finalement
la droite n'irai pas survivre en
essayant de s'élargir avec faut que les
choses soient très claires chacun fera
comme il voudra moi je n'ai jamais
jamais considéré qu'une famille
politique
gagner des voix en allant sur un
territoire qui n'était pas le sien
bon notre famille politique a son
histoire sa cohérence avec des moments
de flux et des moments de reflux
mais c'est pas parce qu'on est dans des
moments de reflux qu' on doit faire tout
et n'importe quoi
nous sommes un parti profondément
européen construit lucide sur les
faiblesses de l'europe mais profondément
européen nous sommes tous cas moi c'est
la ligne que je d'efforts pour un modèle
qui est la foi donne de la liberté aux
entreprises mais qui socialement
attentif aux plus modestes nos
compatriotes et le maire de meaux que je
suis peu emporté mille témoignage de
cette nécessité d'un équilibre entre les
deux et enfin troisièmement je suis pour
une une approche régaliennes et
extrêmement ferme sur les questions de
sécurité de justice et d'immigration et
de laïcité bon ça vous fait un corpus
qui tient la route
après il se trouve que macron pour toute
une série de raisons fait plutôt cette
politique là pourquoi voulez vous que je
m'y oppose ce serait absurde qui n'aille
pas assez loin dans certains domaines
oui sans doute
on pourrait le dire où il ya des vrais
rêves des vrais domaine où il faut aller
plus loin
enfin de là à s'opposer de manière
violente radical je pense que je pense
que du coup ça ça ramène ceux qui le
font à une optique qui est celle qui
excelle de l'extrême droite française
quand vous entendez laurent wauquiez
après la manifestation du 1er mai qu'est
votre caisse charlotte avec les
problèmes de terribles des black blocks
quand il a parlé d'une dénoncé une
faillite de l'état ça vous a heurté
liberté ni porter ses marques face à des
formules formule
alors au sein des républicains il ya
différentes stratégies pas remisé pour
autant la fermeté extrême est nécessaire
face aux mba mise bien sûr il n'y a pas
de débat là dessus aussi au sein des
républicains il ya différentes
stratégies parmi ceux qui ne soutiennent
pas laurent wauquiez il ya par exemple
xavier bertrand qui a quitté le parti se
réclament toujours de la droite
j'imagine qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette stratégie par là par la face nord
si je puis dire en fait je ne porte pas
de jugement poussez vous savez j'ai fait
le choix moi de me je vous disais tout à
l'heure de prendre pas mal de recul par
rapport aux commentaires quotidiens
je pense que chacun doit faire comme il
comme il le sent moi j'ai choisi j'ai
pas choisi de démissionner choisi de
rester dans ma famille politique pour
laquelle j'ai un attachement profond
anciens qui fait par exemple que j'ai
moi soutenu la démarche de jacques
chirac qui avait rassemblé les
gaullistes les libéraux les centristes
j'avais il ya dix ans soutenu nicolas
sarkozy dans cette même idée d'une
famille politique capable en rassemblant
de réformer beaucoup notre pays bas ont
malheureusement les choses ce ne sont
pas toujours passé comme on le
souhaitait mais peu importe
en tout cas moi je n'ai aucune intention
de quitter cette famille politique en
même temps dès lors qu' il n'y a pas d'
approche de rassemblement de la part de
sa direction
forcément ça crée des comportements de
rejet et xavier il a évidemment mal vécu
tout ça et je peux pas je le comprends
c'est pas le choix que j'ai fait mais je
le comprends maintenant qu'on entend
beaucoup en tout cas aujourd'hui et
fortement parce que laurent wauquiez il
a un peu du mal mais c'est jean luc
mélenchon on dit aujourd'hui que c'est
le premier opposant à emmanuel macron
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ça
fait les affaires du président
finalement de se retrouver avec des
partis traditionnels
lr et ps vaut à bois et des extrêmes à
présent mais ça c'est sûr que ça fait
c'est affaire monsieur macron bien sûr
et sur comment voulez-vous faire les
choses autrement
d'ailleurs elles le sont lui chez bull
qu'elle s'engage le le montre très bien
en disant que les français
majoritairement sont un peu déçus par
son action mais en même temps ne vois
personne d'autre à sa place
comment vous l'expliquez tout simplement
personne n'arrive à émerger
mais vous savez c'est assez simple on
est au lendemain d'une élection
présidentielle et pour les français qui
sont des vieux habitués la démocratie le
contrat il est pour cinq ans c'est la
force de nos institutions c'est pour ça
qu'il faut pas en changer nos
institutions
honnêtement contrairement à l'italie qui
est un régime de grande instabilité même
l'allemagne ou la grande-bretagne la
france les gens savent qui a un contrat
de cinq ans avec leur président donc
aujourd'hui considèrent que c'est lui et
personne d'autre
après oui c'est vrai que le principal
opposant basse et un opposant très
radicaliser qui tient des propos
d'ailleurs certains égards je parle de
jean luc mélenchon totalement
irresponsable avoir osé expliquer que
que les violences le jour du 1er mai
était le fait de l'extrême droite alors
que tout le monde sait que c'est des
mouvements d'extrême gauche
c'est une honte nous la de sa part de
l'avoir fait c'est irresponsable bon
mais je crois que ça va avec le
personnage c'est vous avez des partis
populistes et des partis de gouvernement
l'extrême droite extrême gauche ce sont
des partis populistes alors vous avez
donc réitéré aujourd'hui la votre
attachement bien sûr à votre famille
politique jean-françois copé néanmoins
vous prenez une alliance une nouvelle
alliance pour la ville de paris on
voulait que je sois battu avec une
alliance éventuellement entre et l'air
et la république en mars
est ce que c'est un schéma que vous
imaginez se reproduire s'il a lieu à
paris dans d'autres villes ou à même à
un autre niveau que la commune lors des
prochains rendez vous des retours à
paris c'était absolument indispensable
c'est une question de survie pour la
banlieue ou c'est moi je suis maire
d'une grande ville de la grande banlieue
prendre à droite un mot on peut plus
arriver à paris moi je pense à ces
dizaines de milliers de salariés qui
sont dans tout le grand test de paris
tout à seine-et-marne se mettent des
heures pour rejoindre paris pour aller
travailler c'est un cauchemar
tout ça parce que il n'y a plus de
politique des transports digne de ce nom
madame hidalgo pense qu'elle vit dans un
village pour complaire à quelques-uns de
ses électeurs et ne se rend plus compte
que tout cela donne une image de morgue
à l'égard de ce que l'on appelait
autrefois les banlieusards qui est une
formule très péjorative mai mais qui
apportent leur force de travail au
parisien et je trouve que c'est une
image dramatique est que chaque mois qui
passe ça s'aggravait donc je pense que
c'est une véritable mission d'intérêt
général que de faire en sorte que madame
hidalgo ne soit plus maire de paris et
pour y arriver si l'on doit faire une
alliance entre les républicains et en
marche pour ces éléments qui sont les
plus à droite
il ya plein de gens atteints qui sont
droites chaire marche eh bien je crois
que c'est une bonne chose et c'est un
schéma qu'on pourra conduire dans
d'autres villes où nous regardent maire
de meaux en prêchant à mes administrés
qui doivent aller à paris et pour le
reste j'ai bien compris que les
décisions de ceux prenant toujours pas
sur le grand paris allait falloir que
nous nous organisions sur le territoire
du nord de la seine et marne et c soit
quoi dans réfléchissons avec nos
collègues de roissy je rappelle que la
région est à droite aussi hein c'est pas
anne hidalgo qui a bah oui mais
d'ailleurs tous les transports non
mérite mais valérie pécresse je peux
vous dire qu'elle fait ce qu'elle peut
et très courageusement dans ce contexte
où il n'y a pas de dialogue possible
avec le maire de paris allait troisième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité on va
parler notamment de votre ville jean
françois copé
troisième question que va vous poser
charlotte gauthier
[Musique]
bouchard lot
merci michel ce plan borloo qui a été
présenté il ya quelques jours propose un
grand plan ambitieux pour aider les
banlieues est ce que pour vous la
solution s'ils trouvent vous qui êtes
maire de meaux depuis des années qui
avez vous même pratiqué un plan de
rénovation urbaine
est ce que pour vous ça va dans le bon
sens ma réponse est oui sans sans
hésitation certes toujours y avoir des
choses à modifier améliorer mais c'est
exactement le plan qu'il faut si on veut
trouver des solutions et montrer aux
français que la politique ça sert à
quelque chose dans tous les endroits
charles gautier dans tous les endroits
dans toutes les villes où les maires ont
pris en main la question de la
rénovation urbaine c'est à dire la des
ghettos isation cassant les tours pour y
mettre des immeubles de quatre étages ne
répond ni amis de la sécurité avec des
police municipale armée des caméras de
vidéosurveillance et de l'emploi avec
des zones franches pour défiscaliser les
entreprises qui embauchent des gens du
quartier
dans tous ces endroits la situation
s'est améliorée dans des proportions
remarquables
le problème c'est que tout est à l'arrêt
parce que pour toute une série de
raisons et bien les décideurs sont
éloignés de la réalité des quartiers
difficiles et je pense qu'en réalité les
analyses de christophe guilluy qui sont
très connus aujourd'hui de la france
périphérique qui consiste à dire il ya
d'un côté ceux qui sont d'ors ville et
banlieue et ceux qui sont dehors ceux
qui sont dans les campagnes est
imparfaite
c'est pas de france ces trois france il
ya une france des grandes villes des
centres qui décident d'une france des
campagnes très abandonné mais une france
des banlieues qui n'attend que cet
engagement là pour s'en sortir et par
tout ça c'est fait ça marche et voilà et
si j'avais d'ailleurs un reproche à
faire je le lui dire au rapport de jean
louis borloo c'est qu'on ne valorise pas
assez les réussites il y a des quartiers
où le cycle la délinquance a été diminué
par deux en quelques années je peux en
porter témoignage amont donc en vérité
les solutions elles existaient résultats
sont là simplement
eh bien il n'y a pas assez de quartier
où ça s'est fait parce qu'à pas à ces
mères qui ont eu les moyens de le faire
et que ce qui parfois pouvait le faire
non pas toujours
vous avez les moyens par exemple on
arrive vous avez d'un plan de rénovation
qui se poursuit alors c'est formidable
quand il ya de l'argent l'argent est là
bien sûr bien sûr mais mais mais il ya
évidemment à donner une nouvelle
impulsion à tout ça mais par tout ça
c'est fait c'est ce que je vous dis
c'est une réussite et nous avions
faudrait juste de gif nous avions 20
tours a beau nous en avions démoli nous
en avons des bolides 13 sur les
quartiers qui ont été reconstruits à la
place c'est une autre vie et comme par
hasard dans ces endroits là le chômage a
baissé
la délinquance a baissé le front
national a baissé son 2e 2e chiffre que
je veux vous donner qui me paraît
vraiment important la délinquance à mot
par le fait que nous avons mis en place
cette police municipale armée des
caméras un partenariat avec le parquet
les principaux de collèges la police
nationale
la délinquance a été diminué par deux
nous étions à 110 crimes et délits pour
1000 habitants par an on aidé à 52 bon
pourquoi je vous donne ses deux chiffres
parce que la politique ça doit être
aussi l'âme de mesurer des résultats
ce que les français reprochent beaucoup
à leurs élus c'est de ne pas avoir de
résultats et bien les élus locaux ils en
ont des résultats parce qu'il sinon ils
échouent et la vérité c'est que je
regrette que monsieur macron ne prennent
pas suffisamment la mesure de sa et donc
moi mon objectif en m'engageant aux
côtés jean-louis borloo pour la défense
de ce plan c'est de mettre un peu l'épée
dans les reins du gouvernement c'est de
dire maintenant ça suffit il faut que
vous preniez conscience que si vous ne
le faites pas eh bien eh bien vous aurez
de quoi être alors désavoué par les
français parliez de sécurité le volet
sécurité c'est pas un petit peu le grand
absent de ce plan borloo alors c'est pas
le grand absent mais c'est vrai je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin et c'est un
des domaines je m'en suis expliqué
d'ailleurs avec jean louis borloo sur
lequel moi j'aurai un ensemble de
propositions très concrètes à faire
je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin en
matière de sécurité elle propose
isabelle je pense par exemple de manière
très claire que la police nationale
malheureusement compte tenu des
restrictions budgétaires très
regrettable de nuit dix ans n'ont plus
les moyens d'être sur place
il faut donc encourager massivement les
maires avoir des police municipale armée
au delà des communes de 10000 habitants
ça doit être de mon point de vue
maintenant une obligation légale avec
des moyens financiers et donc repensé et
d'ailleurs
ce point dû repenser les finances
locales mais c'est un un sujet sur
lequel je veux pas être trop long bien
j'irai beaucoup pâti on va écouter jean
louis borloo justement qui énumère
certaines des difficultés de ces
quartiers là est également des zones
rurales dit il
nous sommes dans une organisation
française qui fait qu' il y a moins de
moyens là où il ya plus de besoin voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça il y a deux
fois moins de 2 de médecins de
gynécologues des spécialistes c'est plus
compliqué de payer moins de transport en
commun fait tout est plus compliqué
alors donc quelle va être votre apport
personnel vous avez quoi vous vous
travaillez combattre à ses côtés d'une
certaine manière nous virer de vue vous
savez les versements se parlent très
souvent oui
d'abord parce qu'on a on a en commun
d'avoir mené j'étais bis du budget était
mise de la ville ce qui a abouti à la
première en rue l'acoss agence national
qui regroupait tous ces crédits sous le
gouvernement de jacques chirac
mais encore une fois la grande vertu de
de cette démarche de jean-louis borloo
sais qui mais du concret sur la table il
a totalement raison et moi je pense
qu'il faut faire exactement comme ça il
a raison oui il ya une pénurie de
médecins en france mais dans les
quartiers difficiles en particulier
oui il a raison les quartiers difficiles
sont vraiment difficile pour certains
médecins vous savez ils ont du mal à
intervenir mais si la red bull avait
tout à fait raison mais c'est donc pour
cela que l'on peut mettre en place des
systèmes qui permettent de sécuriser
tout cela est donc il faut mettre les
moyens
quand vous avez des tour de 15 étages
parfois même des caravanes fear 3 bars
avec une colonne centrale l'ascenseur
qui seraient tous les trois étages comme
nous en avons un mot inutile de vous
dire que c'est juste la porte ouverte à
toutes les violences et à tous les non
droit quand vous les démolisse et eybens
et plus la même chose pour les
trafiquants et voyous et donc c'est ça
aussi l'objectif parce que vous y mettez
à la place des immeubles à taille
humaine vous mettez de l'accession à la
propriété là où il ya que des logements
sociaux vous repensez les tôles et le
plan de circulation on vous y mettez en
bas d'immeubles des commerces des
entreprises qui embauchent des gens du
quartier en étant défiscalisées voilà
typiquement des choses concrètes qui
change tout et c'est ça qui est à mon
sens de mon point de vue la première
vertu de la démarche de jean-louis
borloo
et donc j'ai décidé de m'engager à ces
conneries parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'ils aient des voix du terrain qui
puisse apporter ce témoignage
ayant la chance d'être le maire d'une
ville où nous avons mis ses politiques
en oeuvre et où elles ont marché
eh bien il faut apporter ces témoignages
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres
regardez ce qu'a fait pierre bédier à
mantes-la-jolie ce qu'a fait patrick
devedjian à antony tu as un d'autres
villes de la grande banlieue parisienne
lyonnaise marseillaise ça ce sont des
choses qu'il faut raconter vous dites
monsieur copé qu'il faut y mettre des
moyens est ce que c'est pas paradoxal
d'envisager un plan à plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros quand un plan de 50
milliards d'économies est imposé aux
communes et qui fait crier les communes
depuis le quinquennat hollande déjà mais
c'est encore en cours comment est-ce
qu'on peut allier les deux c'est
possible on peut pas lier les deux ça
n'aurait pas de sens vous avez tout à
fait raison
faut pas allier les deux il faut trouver
des circuits de financement qui soit un
petit peu différent en réalité il ya pas
que l'état qui doit payer et pas que
l'état il faut voir comment ils étaient
embarrassés on a vu jean louis borloo
très embarrassé sur le chiffrage d'une
place humer les 48 wilayas
il a raison ah bah oui mais c'est vous
dire pour d'où le scepticisme réservés
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on fait
quand on veut casser une idée à et c'est
l'ancien ministre du budget qui vous le
dit c'est très facile quand on veut dire
qu'un plan doit pas marcher de sortir un
chiffre la vérité c'est que ce qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est comment
identifier des initiatives et de voir
comment chacune de ces initiatives
peuvent être mises en oeuvre
je voudrais vous prendre un exemple il y
a dans ces quartiers des situations de
misère sociale extrêmement important des
problèmes d'obésité qui sont aujourd'hui
constaté en france alors que vous savez
que pendant des années nous avions
préserver notre pays de ceux de ses
problèmes qui sont des véritables reines
de sociétés notamment pour les enfants
nous avons des problèmes de violence du
quotidien qui sont extraordinairement
difficile à vivre
face à cela il y a manière d'apporter
des réponses très concrètes qui parfois
peuvent se faire à travers du mécénat
peuvent se faire à travers des
partenariats du bénévolat
nous avons par exemple à mots ouverts
une maison du diabète et de l'obésité
objectif accompagner des familles sur
les questions d'éducation alimentaire de
prévention nous avons énormément de
visiteurs naturellement et
a été montée de bric et broc ça n'a pas
coûté bien cher est en réalité derrière
cela et bien c'est des dizaines et des
dizaines de familles au quotidien qui
voit des solutions concrètes
ça si vous les mettez dans les 48
milliards eh ben vous casser le dossier
vous êtes enthousiaste pour le plan
borloo mais ce n'est pas le cas de la
majorité des français d'après notre
sondage opinionway presque le plan
borloo sera efficace selon vous et bien
il y à 53% de non que traduit ce nom
selon vous on sent qu'il ya une forme de
lassitude peut être de l'opinion
publique mais je ne sais pas regarder
mais il ya 43 pour cent quarante points
43 qui y croient mais il ya une majorité
qui dit non mais si énorme 43% qui
croient vous rendez compte
éveil tout d'abord il faut quand même
voir que ces soucis un sondage sur toute
la population française y compris celles
qui habitent dans les campagnes celles
qui habitent dans des centres villes
dont qui ne sont pas confrontés à ça
donc il ya quelque part un message qui
est adressé
deuxièmement qu'il y ait de la part
d'une partie de français du scepticisme
assez normal ça fait des années et des
années qu'on les bat l'arrêt de
fractures peut-être ça c'est aussi un
signe mais attention à tous ces boules
c'est des mots tellement guerriau des
anciens plus que ça veut dire fracture
pas fracturé je ne sais pas il ya
forcément des débats ça s'appelle un
débat déjà une croix des gens qui
croient pas c'est pas grave on peut être
pas être toujours d'accord sur tout un
plan n'est pas bon parce que 90 % et
pour ça peut même plus tôt même
inquiétant déjà qu'on change rien du bon
donc là l'intérêt c'est qu'on fait
bouger les lignes
je trouve que c'est une démarche qui
était actuellement être intéressante qui
politiquement une nouvelle et qui mérite
d'être tenté et là pour le coup il
appartient au gouvernement de ne pas
faire la sourde oreille
parce que si fait la sourde oreille et
ben il va manquer un rendez vous
historique et 100 des électeurs lui
reprocheront on a noté que ça n'était
pas emmanuel macron lui-même qui
recevait le rapport de jean louis borloo
oui on a tous noté vous l'avez noté en
tous les cas vous avez effectivement
reconnu que le volet sécurité
inquiète un préalable manqué dans le
plan borloo qui refuse également vous
l'avez noté d'évoquer le communautarisme
et pourtant c'est un nouveau combat
oui jean-françois vous le regrettez
aussi non mais moi je vais le faire vous
allez faire à ses côtés vous l'avez dit
à jean-louis borloo que ce point-là été
abordés j'aime pas non mais c'est
possible la question c'est pour savoir
si ça va nous faire nous séparer
officiellement pas spécialement ma femme
et moi je c'est un des combats de ma vie
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi je
renoncerais c'est pas le sujet et puis
d'abord ce se prend un programme il est
très vaste mais moi je pense qu'il faut
pas lâcher sur le communautarisme c'est
un point majeur oui vous l'avez proposer
des choses là dessus déjà non
j'attendais de vous voir mais comment
mais j'ai plein de choses à dire
là-dessus bien triste comment luttons
contre le communautarisme et bien il
faut d'abord commencer par lutter contre
les ghettos
quand vous avez des quartiers qui ne
sont composés que de tours
vous avez 100 % de logements sociaux ou
vous n'y trouvez qu une seule et même
catégorie de population qui sont
généralement des communautés issues de
tel ou tel pays qui sont des pays
d'immigration qui sont venus en france
et bien forcément vous créez du
communautarisme c'est à dire une espèce
de sentiment de comportements d'un
certain nombre de gens qui pensent que
les règles de leur communauté sont
supérieures aux lois de la république
bon eh bien moi je pense que il faut
préserver
l'attachement une communauté ça pose
aucun problème on a tous un attachement
personnel à sa communauté assez
communauté des religieuses politiques
sportives géographique c'est pas un
problème dès lors que l'on accepte bien
que les règles de sa communauté sont
subordonnées aux lois de la république
si ce n'est pas le cas là ça devient du
communautarisme est mon combat il est de
dire mélange on our un peu veillons à se
respecter à se parler et à s'écouter et
pour ça il faut plus qu'on ait peur les
uns des autres donc il faut le pré
requis de la sécurité deuxième prérequis
déghettoïser donc casser ces fameuses
tours qui enferme les gens dans des
véritables prisons des deux fêtes et
veillons à avoir suffisamment d espace
public pour que les gens puissent se
rencontrer sans avoir peur les uns des
autres
qu'avez vous pensé du mal tout avec un
rôle majeur pour l'école de la
république qu'avez vous pensé du débat
la prise en compte aujourd'hui du nouvel
antisémitisme des quartiers avec le
manifeste du
parisien qui a créé tout un débat quelle
est votre position sur c'est une réalité
mais qu'il faut arrêter de le nier je
pense qu'il ya une montée très très
significative et inquiétante de
l'antisémitisme qui se voit dans un
certain nombre de quartiers qui touche
beaucoup de nos compatriotes et et cette
situation est bien elle est intolérable
parce qu'elle rappelle évidemment les
heures les plus sombres de l'histoire
et comme vous le savez peut-être moi je
je je suis ce que je suis aujourd'hui
parce que je suis issu d'une famille qui
a été sauvés par des justes
pendant la guerre de 40 à aubusson et
qu'elle mes parents ont toujours dit que
la france était un grand pays qu'on
devait lui rendre ce qu'elle nous avait
donné et qui certes y avait des
mais qui avait aussi des justes et je
pense que ça ça doit être notre chemin
nous vous souscrivez à 100% à ce qu'ils
étaient créés dans cette tribune même
les termes qui ont peu choqué notamment
sur l'épuration ethnique à bas bruit ou
c'est une réalité pour certains juifs
par exemple un mot pas un mot non pas
non non non non mais je pense qu'à une
réalité il faut pas la nier il faut pas
s'arrêter sur les mots il faut le parfum
y avoir il faut bien voir de quoi il
s'agit il y à des écoles des classes
dans lesquelles on ne peut pas enseigner
la shoah
il y à des familles qui aujourd'hui sont
insultés dans la rue menacé tout ça
existe si on le nid alors n'est pas
républicain merci jean françois copé
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui à
d'abord accepté notre invitation puisque
c'est vrai vous est peu présent dans les
médias
puisque vous êtes bien un petit peu en
retraite peut-être pour mieux revenir
demain nous aurons parleront merci à
vous merci chers qu'en france air a très
vite
[Musique]